luego de unos meses turbulentos netflix
sufre otro revuelo en algunos países
árabes arabia saudita los emiratos
árabes son dos de las seis naciones del
golfo que han pedido a la compañía
retirar lo que consideran como contenido
ofensivo de su plataforma el comunicado
conjunto no especifica a qué contenido
se refieren pero junto al comunicado la
televisión estatal saudita emitió un
clip de unos dibujos animados en netflix
con dos mujeres besándose aunque las
imágenes estaban difuminadas el
comunicado del consejo de cooperación
del golfo acusa a programas sin
especificar de contradecir los
principios y valores islámicos y
sociales
y añade en caso de que dicho contenido
siga en emisión se tomarán medidas
legales sin elaborar netflix ha estado
defendiéndose de su competencia no sólo
de hb o amazon sino cada vez más de
streams regionales como el servicio
sauditas ágil a principios de año
algunos países musulmanes vetaron de los
cines la película de disney lightyear
por un breve beso entre personajes del
mismo sexo tras ello su sistema de
streaming disney blast dijo que su
contenido debería ir acorde a las
regulaciones locales anteriormente la
californiana netflix ya ha limitado su
contenido en arabia saudita en 2019
activistas criticaron a la plataforma
por emitir un show de comedia que
criticaba al príncipe mohammed por el
asesinato del periodista yamaha show